okay we didn't see a dubois make that  queen  move just now instead he's offered  another pawn  for dubois to take these guys do not  care about material  um wow look at magnus's face as well  he's surprised by that last move by  duboff  i'm surprised too suddenly breaking from  his character he going for a pawn when  he should have been going for the  opponent's king is there no now  a check what is it okay so  he has lined up the queen on the rook so  that knight  is forced to move and now the pawn is in  the queen's eyesight so  you're gonna take the pawn yeah so white  is now going to play queen takes pawn  check  black's king is suddenly one in danger  oh wow  magnus doesn't do that instead he goes  for a bigger fish in the sea  instead he attacks the knight and the  knight cannot move  because the queen are facing two seconds  for daniel  and that's it's game over duboff has  resigned actually the knight cannot move  the night is lost  pin and win that's what they